welcome back everyone this is part two
in our series on methods and metrics
we're going to be talking about
classifier metrics i'm sort of assuming
that the metrics i'll be discussing are
broadly familiar to us
i think that's a chance for us to step
back and be reflective about what values
these familiar metrics actually encode
because that really is the name of the
game here no matter what kind of task
you're working on or what the structure
of your model is like it's just
fundamentally true that different
evaluation metrics will encode different
values different goals you have for your
system and different kinds of hypothesis
that you might be pursuing you could
hear in that that really fundamentally
choosing a metric is a crucial aspect to
any kind of experimental work it's a
fundamental step in how we
operationalize hypotheses in terms of
data and models and model comparisons
as a result you should feel free for
whatever task you're working on to
motivate new metrics or specific uses of
existing metrics depending on what your
actual goals for your experiments
actually are
relatedly for established tasks you'll
probably feel some pressure to use
specific well-established metrics but
you should always as a scientist feel
empowered to push back if you feel that
the accepted metrics
are not reflective of your hypothesis or
are distorting our notions of progress
somehow because remember
areas of research can stagnate due to
poor metrics and so we have to be
vigilant we have to be on the lookout
for cases in which the metrics we've
accepted might be at odds with the
actual goals we have for the research
we're doing
let's begin our discussion of classifier
metrics by talking about confusion
matrices a pretty fundamental data
structure for a lot of the calculations
that we'll perform
so by convention for my confusion
matrices i'll have the actual labels
going across the rows here and across
the columns i'll have the predictions
from some classifier model so you can
see in this confusion matrix that there
were 15 cases in which the model
predicted positive and the actual label
was positive where there whereas there
are 10 cases where the actual label was
positive and the model predicted
negative and so forth for the other
values in this table
i think that seems familiar it's
something we can take for granted but we
should remember
that behind the scenes here a threshold
was imposed in order to create these
categorical predictions
by and large classifier models that we
use today
predict probability distributions over
the labels and so in order to create an
actual categorical prediction we decided
for example that the label with the
maximum probability would be the true
one and that was the result of that
decision was used to aggregate this
table but of course different choices of
that threshold might give very different
results and there might be context in
which we want to explore the full range
of probabilistic predictions that's
something i'll return to at the end of
the screencast
final note about this it can be helpful
in the context of confusion matrices to
add a column or what's called support
which is simply the number of actual
true instances that fall into each class
so there are 125 positive instances in
this corpus 35 negative and over a
thousand that fall in the neutral
category and that's already illuminating
about how specific metrics might deal
with that extremely imbalanced
vector of support values
let's start with accuracy by far the
most famous and familiar of all the
classifier metrics accuracy is simply
the number of correct predictions
divided by the total number of examples
in terms of our confusion matrices that
is just the sum of all the values along
the diagonal divided by the sum of all
the values that are in this table
the bounds are zero and one of course
with zero the worst and one the best
in terms of the value encoded by
accuracy i would say it's an attempt to
answer the question how often is the
system correct
and that kind of feeds into the
weaknesses here so the weaknesses are
first there's no per class notion of
accuracy not directly we just get a
single holistic number and relatedly
there is just a complete failure to
control for class size
so you can see for example in this
confusion matrix that performance on the
neutral class will completely dominate
the accuracy
values and it's to the point in this
table where
no matter how much progress we make on
the positive and negative classes
because they are so much smaller in
terms of their support than neutral that
kind of progress is unlikely to be
reflected in our accuracy values and
that's why if you return to the value
encoded you can see that just at a raw
fundamental level it is simply answering
how often is the system correct
another thing to keep in mind is that
for many classifier models
the loss for those models is what's
called the cross entropy loss it's also
called the negative log loss
inside kit learn
and that value is inversely proportional
to accuracy
the takeaway there is that even as we
might choose other metrics to compare
models and evaluate models we should
keep in mind that our classifiers
themselves are kind of engines for
trying to maximize accuracy and so they
are likely to inherit whatever
properties and values and strengths and
weaknesses are inherent in the accuracy
calculation which as we'll see could be
at odds with our actual values for the
system that we're developing
and that kind of feeds nicely into
precision recall and f scores which are
attempts to make up for some of the
weaknesses that you see in accuracy
we'll start with precision this is a per
class notion for a class k it's the
correct predictions for k divided by the
sum of all the guesses for k that were
made by your model
so in terms of this confusion matrix if
we focus on the positive class here the
numerator is the number of correct
predictions for that class divided by
the sum of all the values that are in
this column
and for the negative class we would
repeat that the numerator would be 15
and we would sum over the column and
finally for neutral the numerator would
be a thousand and we would again sum
over this column and that leads to this
vector of precision values that you see
along the bottom here
the bounds of precision are zero and one
approximately with zero the worst and
one the best there is an important
caveat here though
precision is technically undefined in
situations where a model makes no
predictions about a given class because
in that situation you're dividing by
zero and that's technically undefined it
is common practice to map those to zero
but we should keep in mind that we were
making that extra decision
the value encoded is a kind of
conservative one we're going to penalize
incorrect guesses for a certain class
so you can imagine that a failure mode
there is to just rarely guess a certain
class that is the core weakness you can
achieve high precision
for a class k simply by rarely guessing
k
so we'll obviously need to offset that
with some other pressure
and by and large the offset pressure is
recall
recall is again a per class notion for a
class k it's going to be the correct
predictions for k divided by the sum of
all the true members of k
so now we're going to operate row right
row wise we focus on the positive class
our numerator is 15 the number of true
predictions for the positive class
divided by the sum of all the values
along the rows that is all the true
members of that class for positive that
gives us a recall value of 0.12 and we
can repeat that for the other two rows
the bounds are zero and one the zero are
the worst and one the best
the value encoded is a permissive one we
want to penalize missed true cases we
would like to make a lot of predictions
about a class in order to avoid leaving
any out so to speak and that kind of
leads into the core weakness we can
achieve high recall for a class k
simply by always guessing k
never mind the mistakes as long as we
get all the actual cases into our
predictions we're doing well by recall
and you can hear in that that it's
important to offset this pressure by
something else not standardly precision
and the way we offset these two
pressures is typically with f scores
so f scores are a harmonic mean of the
precision and recall scores it's again a
per class notion and it has this
weighting value beta if we want to
evenly balance precision and recall then
we set beta to 1.
so here's that confusion matrix again
and along this column here i've given
the per class f1 values here
the bounds are 0 and 1 as before with 0
the worst and one the best and you can
count on the fact that the f1 score for
a class will always fall between the
precision and recall classes because
it's a kind of an average it's the
harmonic mean
what's the value encoded the best way i
can say this is that we're essentially
trying to answer the question for a
given class k how much do predictions
for k align with true instances of k
that is aligning with both precision and
recall as pressures and then we can use
the beta value to control how much
weight we place on precision versus
recall
what are the weaknesses of f-scores well
i can really think of two
the first is that there's no
normalization for the size of the data
set because of the way we use the
denominators for the row and column sums
and relatedly for a given class that we
decide to focus on we actually ignore
most of the data that's in the table
consider the fact that if we decide to
calculate the f1 score for the positive
class we pay attention to these column
values and these row values but we
completely ignore these four values here
they're just not involved in the
calculation at all and as a result
the positive class f1 score might give a
distorted picture of what the model's
predictions are actually like in virtue
of the fact that they leave out so much
of the data here as you can see
now
because f scores are a per-class notion
i think that's useful in the sense that
it gives us a perspective on each one of
the classes separately but for many
kinds of model evaluations we need a
summary number a single number that we
can use to compare models and assess
overall progress
so we're going to do some kind of
averaging and i'd like to offer you
three ways that we might average these f
scores macro averaging weighted
averaging and micro averaging and as
you'll see these encode quite different
values about how we want to think about
the f scores
macro averaging is a kind of averaging
that we've done
at various points throughout the quarter
it is simply the arithmetic mean
of all the per category f1 scores so
it's just the mean of the values along
this column
its bounds are zero and one with zero
the worst and one the best
what value does encode well it's the
same values that we get from f scores
plus the additional and non-trivial
assumption that all of the classes are
equal regardless of size differences
between them
right and that kind of feeds into the
weaknesses here a classifier that does
well only on the small classes might not
actually do well in the real world if
you imagine counterfactually that for
our given model here we had really
outstanding f1 scores for positive and
negative and really low for neutral that
might really be at odds with how this
classifier would behave in the world
assuming that most of the examples that
are streaming in are in the neutral
category
relatedly a classifier that does well
only on large classes might do poorly on
the small but nonetheless vital classes
that are in our data and that just
reflects the fact that very often in nlp
it's the small classes that are the most
precious the ones that we care about the
most and we're not reflecting that kind
of asymmetry on our values by simply
taking the average of all these f scores
weighted average f scores will give a
very different perspective on model
performance
in this case we are again just going to
take an average of the f1 scores but now
weighted by the amount of support for
each one of the classes
that again has bound zero to one with
zero the worst and one the best
the value encoded is the same as the
values that we get for the f scores but
now with the added assumption that the
size of the classes the amount of
support really does matter
and that's going to feed into the
weaknesses and the fundamental thing
here is that large classes will dominate
just as with accuracy the larger our
class is the more it's going to
contribute to our overall summary number
and that can lead to the kind of
problematic uh situation where the small
classes are just not relevant for the
evaluation metric
that could reflect your values because
if what you really care about is raw
rate of correct predictions you might
want to weight the larger classes more
heavily
but again for many contexts in nlp we
really care about how much progress we
can make on the small but nonetheless
important classes and so in those
contexts weighted averaging is probably
not the right choice
the final averaging scheme that i'd like
to consider is micro averaged f-scores
this will be very similar to weighted
averaging of f1 scores and is directly
connected to accuracy
the way this works is a little bit
involved we start with this core
confusion matrix and we're going to
break it down into three
smaller confusion matrices one per class
so you can see this one on the left here
is for the positive class the yeses are
15 and the no's are the sum of these two
values here along this row
the nose or the 20 which is the sum of
these two values and then this no no
category is all the remaining data in
this quadrant here
we repeat that same procedure for the
negative class and for the neutral class
and then we simply sum up those three
smaller tables into one big yes no
confusion matrix and calculate the f1
scores per category
that gives us two scores here one for
yes and one for no
the bounds on this are zero and one with
zero the worst and one the best
the value encoded is really easy to
state
macro averaged f1 scores for the yes
category are equivalent to accuracy
scores numerically so that's identical
in terms of that metric and we have this
additional problem now that well we have
the same kind of value reflected as we
have for the weighted f scores or for
accuracy but now we have brought in an
additional source of uncertainty which
is we have a number for the yes category
and the no category and hence no single
summary number the convention in the
literature is to focus on the yes
category but that simply brings us back
to accuracy with a more involved
calculation so that's obviously not very
productive and i would say as a result
here the two real choices that you want
to make are between macro averaging
and weighted averaging of your f1 scores
and again that will come down to what
your fundamental values are and what
hypotheses you're pursuing
the final point i want to make is that
thus far we have operated in terms of
the confusion matrix which involved
imposing a threshold on probabilistic
predictions in order to create
categorical values that we could then
compare with precision and recall and so
forth
precision and recall curves are offer a
fundamentally different perspective
in this case instead of imposing one
threshold we'll take every possible
value that's predicted by our classifier
to be a potential threshold and
essentially create a bunch of confusion
matrices based on that successive series
of thresholds
and then we can plot the trade-off
between precision here along the y-axis
and recall along the x-axis for all
those different notions of threshold and
that can be really illuminating in terms
of helping us see how our system trades
precision and recall against each other
and help us find based on values that we
have about our problem and our goals
what the optimal balance between
precision and recall actually is
and then if you do need a summary number
of this entire table
average precision which is implemented
in scikit-learn is a standard way of
summarizing the entire curve with a
single number without though imposing
that single threshold that was so much
shaping all of the previous metrics that
we discussed
you